let's go next to our caller from the 3-1
to area code who's calling today from
3-1 to me that's you yeah who's this oh
yeah this is Chris I'm from Chicago I
was just watching your video about like
that you know like the Elizabeth
Warren's gun safety plan yep I think a
lot of it would work and I'm not really
knocking it too much but I don't know
like what do you think about like some
people on the Left who don't really I
don't know like a lot of people say they
don't feel safe about stuff like but you
know they don't feel safe with what what
do you mean well like there's something
left is to say like well you know like I
think that like I don't know how to
describe this they say that like it
would only affect a certain group of
people like there's some things that
I've read on this right like it was like
so they have like background checks on
all guns and online purchases but you
know that's reasonable you know like and
you have like an 18 plus restriction on
the cells and like you know you get rid
of that boyfriend loophole like I'm
reading this like that cuz I the screen
cap of it but do you mean ABCs I
understand Christopher are you saying
some people say that only people who
abide by the law will be affected by
different laws so that in reality like
criminals are just going to illegally
get guns either way so who what does it
matter you know oh no no I'm just saying
like that you'll start like because like
I do agree with a lot of them right like
because you know I'm from Illinois and
like it's illegal for people from
Indiana or certain parts of Illinois to
you know make sells like in certain
areas right because like that's where
like most of the guns come from yeah I'm
just not sure like how beneficial it
would be Michael Reese it's like if a
lot of people would even be on track
with that and I just one of your
thoughts than that oh well yeah so I
mean you you are right about one thing
which is that this has been studied in a
lot of different countries and within
states just one change like for example
making background checks completely
Universal for all transactions as an
example that alone is not going to have
a significant impact but the way that
these things work is when you put
together like a package of changes
that's when you get a more significant
impact and it does decrease the
availability of gun
to be illegally transacted as well
that's often ignored so I think you're
right in that just one of these changes
often feels like it wouldn't do that
much because it actually would not but
there's a lot of studies from many
different countries ranging from you
know Australia all over the place that
tell us that when a package of gun
safety laws is passed together that that
does have a significant impact and it
reduces homicides definitely like and
I'm like I didn't say that to like be
like I was disagreeing with that it's
one of your thoughts about it yeah you
know I think it's be totally work to
give it a try you know psycho chicago's
like a fun place you know thank they
actually one thing that i found really
interesting was that one thing that you
were talking about with the sorts of
sell these firearms right or not the
firearms that what is it like ammunition
in the firearms like the leaves like
kind of cut it like they close in on
their throats a little bit like when you
know they make you cells and I think you
could see like a decreased hopefully
absolutely Chris from Chicago I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much and we will obviously continue
covering that issue thank you take care
yeah that does it for calls today sorry
to everybody I did not get to but I did
my best
we will take calls again and thanks to
everybody who called in